con una participación mínima el frente
de liberación nacional ganó las
elecciones legislativas los resultados
definitivos dan al partido en el poder
un cuarto de los escaños de la asamblea
nacional argelina en primera posición el
frente de liberación nacional obtuvo 105
escaños seguido de las listas de
candidatos independientes que
consiguieron 78 escaños lo que significa
un cambio remarcable en el escenario
político argelino ya que se convierten
en la segunda fuerza de la cámara baja
del parlamento en tercera posición el
msp el partido islamista moderado se
lleva 64 escaños a pesar de que
reivindicó la victoria el día siguiente
de las elecciones el aliado tradicional
del frente de liberación nacional la
agrupación nacional para la democracia
queda en cuarto lugar con 57
parlamentarios
ambos partidos se están desprestigiados
porque se les asocia con el gobierno del
ex presidente buteflika pero la fuerza
en el poder podrá mantener sus alianzas
y seguir con su hoja de ruta aún así la
victoria del frente de liberación
nacional es relativa la fuerza pierde
más de 50 escaños en una
lecciones rechazadas en masa por la
población argelina solo 5 millones de
personas de las 24 llamadas a las urnas
fueron a votar para elegir los 407
diputados de la asamblea por los
próximos cinco años se trata del índice
de participación más bajo en al menos
los últimos 20 años en unas legislativas
fueron múltiples las llamadas al boicot
lanzadas sobre todo por militantes del
movimiento irak que señala que el poder
sigue en manos del establishment militar